there's this insistence now that younger
Generations need whole new vocabularies
distinct from older Generations I when
you heard Oxford English they're they're
celebrating that they're say oh the Gen
Z there they're creating new spaces oh
shut up first of all not creating
anything they're just taking words that
already exist and they're making them
uglier folks I know this video's been
pretty fire but no cap and then but then
the effect is that eventually there's no
shared cultural language anymore each
generation has its own language and I
know you'll say it's always been that
way you know younger kids have always
used lank but that's not really a thing
this is actually a modern phenomenon
like if you were to go uh if you were a
farmer in Pennsylvania in the year 19 or
1827 let's say and you were 45 years old
you you you spoke the same way and used
the same words as your 17-year-old son
it's a vibe there was slang of course
but the slang was shared across
Generations